foreign
hello guys and welcome to yet another
episode of congratulations
[Music]
it's yet another episode of
congratulations and we are you know
we're just kicking it we're having a
good time hey like And subscribe I know
it just started but why don't you just
do us a little favies and like And
subscribe we're trying to grow the
followers uh here on super cold Studios
we got more podcasts coming out lots of
things in the works uh but that's what's
up dude and we love that and uh thank
you very much for watching and
subscribing and liking and commenting
and also uh the Bell notification shits
and all that stuff
um we have a very cool announcement oh
there are those shoes they're right
under the
I [ __ ] couldn't find him great knew
it and also I have great so these shoes
right here the New Balance right here
like them had him here last episode took
them off during the episode little
behind the scenes just so you know they
were they've been there I put them under
the desk took them off during the
episode left saw him as I was leaving I
was like I gotta remember mentally I'll
check that in that these shoes are there
in case I want to wear them before next
week
completely forgot about it and now I'm
seeing them now should have worn the
shoes didn't get to wear shoes this week
because my brain
[ __ ] forgot about it and it's all
good though dude we live and we learn
and we move on in life we [ __ ] rub
with the punches and we we grow as
people we grow as humans and um yeah but
we've got a cool announcement
uh not sure if you're a [ __ ] uh
viewer of my other podcast lifeline on
here at Super cult Studios with my
brother where we give advices on uh
video submissions but we are doing a
Lifeline live episode
um and you can get your tickets now uh
we'll put them in the show notes under
here but it's also on the comments in
the show notes under the lifeline uh
thing you can go to what what is it
watch lifeline.com
yep go to watch lifeline.com and uh sign
up to uh to uh be a call you could call
in and we talk to you it's not just
video submissions so it's live Anything
could happen so go check it out and
stuff
um so yeah that's Lifeline live and um
and that's uh how it's going and then we
got the other uh oh the winners of the
jackets got their jackets the life rips
jackets you got your bomber jackets uh
and people have been asking about them
these are special jackets the 10 people
who got them as winners
I made a different version a colorful
version which you can see right here
boom
um that are going to be for sale it's
definitely limited edition but you can
go to chrisley.com and for uh to get
these jackets while they last I'm not
gonna make more
um but yeah because I know people were
asking and uh so yeah a limited edition
and then also other stuff at mercho
peruse you know eat the brown shits you
know what I mean we got them right here
um so yeah you guys
um speaking of cool clothing look what I
got right here Gap Yeezy Gap slash Yeezy
Balenciaga
and I'm wearing it because Kanye's says
he's done with gap and he's done with
Adidas and he's trying to buy have
Adidas buy out buy him out
uh for a billion dollars
uh days off apparently he said they
offered him a billion dollars to buy him
out so he could just continue doing
Yeezy himself without the aid or in you
know joint conjunction with uh
Adidas and they said a billion dollars
he said no he wants two billion
imagine making that kind of [ __ ] dude he
kind of put I I apparently like 60 of
Adidas shoes sold are Yeezys this is a
[ __ ] thing that I heard I'm not sure
if it's true or not but if that is true
that's unbelievable that's a lot of I
mean he definitely put Adidas back he
helped put Adidas back on the map before
that they had the Shell Toes and it was
the EPMD and that was back in the 80s
and 90s and now
you know Adidas wasn't really kicking up
until Yeezy cut it was kicking a little
bit and then Yeezy started and then it
really started kicking and it's been
Yeezy and Nike and now a little bit New
Balance after
um that basketball player uh
um [ __ ] what's his name
what's his name Kawhi Leonard
whoops didn't want to do whoops whoops
whoops whoops whoops gonna get
demonetized all right I didn't even mean
to do that but that's him
[Music]
wow dude
um anyway
so attack
um he's a robot so uh it's all good he's
a robot and um if you were like my son
he'd be like I am a robot
my son acts like he's a robot so much
it's unbelievable because he likes The
Intergalactic Planetary uh uh another
dimension Beastie Boys video and my son
keeps saying interactive interactive
planetary anoa mentioned anawa mention
and it's so [ __ ] cute
you don't like me talking about my son
eat your heart out you don't let me talk
about my son eat your hearts out
um so and go teleport to a not mention
uh so yeah so
honestly things have been good and I'm
wearing this [ __ ] R.I.P Balenciaga Yeezy
uh Gap [ __ ] uh but I got one of the
[ __ ] only [ __ ] that you know it's all
a publicity stunt dude
he's just saying this [ __ ] and then he's
gonna come out with a [ __ ]
partnership with gap and Adidas again
and it's going to last till two thousand
and [ __ ] 50. uh because you gotta
[ __ ] stay relevant and you stay
relevant by making headlines and you
make Headlines by being bipolar and
acting crazy so uh I need to start doing
that [ __ ] being bipolar and acting
crazy a little bit a little bit more you
know like I I was in the [ __ ] they
picked up some article picked up when I
[ __ ] tried to fight my doctors when I
got my uh deviated septum fixed I needed
need to [ __ ] start fighting more
doctors and [ __ ] or just kind of like
cut ties with companies that don't even
[ __ ] exist that I [ __ ] don't even
have a thing with
whatever I don't know what I'm saying
but I do know is unfucking I went to I
went to my show at the Improv this past
week
and uh I was there and I got a [ __ ]
you know on my keys I have the air tag
[ __ ]
like to always if I need to know where
my keys are I can't find my keys and
also my wife loses [ __ ] a lot so like
I'll just I'll tap it and it'll really
look beep beep beep beep beep beep I'm
like oh I go find the Air Attack where
is it oh for some reason it's under a
book
like nobody in this house has read a
book and I [ __ ] nine years and she's
just it's in the middle of a [ __ ]
book about mental health or some [ __ ]
and um and so I get the key with the air
tag you know and then I go and I drive
so I got him on all my keys I got them
on the [ __ ] keys I got keys for days
I got them on my keys right you know I
got [ __ ]
all the sets of keys
um
David Sullivan as you know he's one of
my friends I talk about him a bit on the
podcast he's like hey man what are we
doing tonight so I'm like
all right let's go
I gotta show at the Improv be here at 9
30. he says Ah man I'll be there you
want me coming not 20.
and I was like just no I got therapy
until
until nine show up at [ __ ] you know
show up at 9 15 how about he's like I'll
be there man
so um
shows up
he's like do I get to see Calvin
Calvin's a night owl right
so he's out he's up my sometimes the
comment says up till 11 no lie you know
whatever works with my schedule that's
what the pediatrician says and that
works with my schedule so if you're mad
at me for being a bad parent be mad at
my pediatrician
um and so
and so he's like uh
shows up sees Calvin Calvin's walking
around like a robot hey you're a robot
huh so he's like all right let's go so
we go now I don't know if you know this
about air tags but it's actually a cool
feature okay
if you're around an air tag for about 20
minutes an air tag will let you know
okay meaning if it's not your Air Tech
so if you were in a backpack and someone
takes an air attack from Apple and
tosses it into that little compartment
on the side that nobody uses except for
[ __ ] Tic Tacs but who you know what I
mean
uh uh and it's on you for more than 20
minutes your phone will go off and let
you know there's an air tag near you and
then this way you know somebody's either
tracking you or whatever the [ __ ] right
and I think that that's a great feature
all right
now
everyone if you look at your phone
and what it literally says is an air tag
uh
an unknown air tag is near you click to
disable okay
that's all you gotta that's all you look
at that and you think oh okay and now if
you're alone in the woods a hundred
percent you click disable if you're at
the mall alone you're a hundred percent
click disable okay
if you're somewhere where you shouldn't
be you 100 click disable Okay now
if you're chilling with your friends
what do you think you do
ignore it
because anyone can get Apple Air tags
and you think you know what
this is probably Bob's air tag
so you ignore it okay
now how shabby do you have to be to know
to ignore that or to see the thing on
the phone and think you know what it's
probably [ __ ] it's Kristen's or Bob's
or [ __ ] Jared's or whatever the [ __ ]
right
not that Savvy right if you're 74 and my
mom she might be like Chris from the
other room
Chris what what is this oh it's fine
just [ __ ] it's Dad's you know
it's to Dad's [ __ ]
it's to the dog or whatever don't worry
okay right I'm 42 and I know it's hard
to believe because I look [ __ ] young
and we know that's a joke because I
looked at myself on the zoom camera the
other day no it was today uh for when I
was in my therapy and I looked
absolutely 49 and it's all good if I
look for none it's all good
but it's the truth
that's all good
um how do I how do I look forget it's
all good okay and it's all good now do I
wish that I had [ __ ] salt and pepper
also in my hair here because I don't
like the way it looks especially yes
it's all good yes it's fine dude am I
aging the way I should be aging yes and
do people on their internet say whoa he
got old and okay yes because I'm [ __ ]
42 and nobody says I'm forever and
that's okay it's all good dessert my
feelings no it's fine but every now and
then I look at myself in the zoom camera
it's bad lighting and yes I look bad and
I feel bad okay but that's neither here
nor there no so if you're in your 40s
you're pretty Savvy with the online
shits you're pretty Savvy with the apps
you're pretty Savvy with Apple products
if you have them
be Savvy you should be Savvy especially
if you're what in a big metropolitan
area like Los Angeles you should be
somewhat savvy
so we're going to the Improv and now how
are we getting there my car and what do
we use to start a car keys and what's on
my keys everyone stay with me air tags
I take the stage at The Improv two
minutes in
now I'm in the middle of high hilarity
okay it breaks my [ __ ] up I don't know
what it is I look at my phone why is my
phone doing this
phone's not doing [ __ ] I'm clueless
because I'm in the middle of a high
octane thing right and I say did you
guys hear that or was it me am I losing
my mind
then I decide to let it go I get off
stage now obviously [ __ ] Crush City
population 210 people in there and uh
I get off stage and David's looking at
me like this
does your phone make that noise
and I was like yeah what and he was like
my phone made to know the same time your
phone made the noise
I said what are you talking about he's
like yeah is there an air attack
following you
and I'm like
hey man what and he said sums up my
phone man
and I was like what are you talking
about he says it set on my phone that
somebody's trying to [ __ ] there's an
attack on my phone and as soon as I hit
the button I disabled it my phone went
off your phone went off
foreign
and I said what what do you
did that what this is my air tag oh
that's the thing that made the noise and
then it Dawns on me it wasn't my phone
it was the actual Air Attack in my
pocket on the [ __ ] Audi keys that are
going
because unsavvy Texan boy Baylor
football David Sullivan is disabling my
[ __ ] air tag
hey guy
get it
hey guy
get savvy
hey guy read all the words do some
Googling
so then that happened and it was all
good and I was like well what the [ __ ]
that's my tag now you disabled it I
gotta see if it works for my [ __ ] he was
like nah but I just untie what does it
mean for my phone though
ding
and I was like what do you mean and he
was like well I just had to disable it
should be okay right and I was like yeah
it's fine
we're [ __ ] go we keep we're hanging
out we're still hanging out
he brings it up again
so what's up with my phone then
and I'm like what and he's like because
I just disabled and that's all I need to
do
and I was like yeah dude it's fine man
it's fine you didn't even need to do
that and he was like but there's nothing
on my phone
and I said
no
no [ __ ] 15 minutes later and he was
like so do I need to do anything
and I said hey
ah [ __ ]
dude
two reasons why it doesn't matter one
you disabled it and two it's mine
no one's trying to [ __ ] kidnap you
dude it's mine we're friends we hang out
you sat in my car for longer than 20
minutes
everything's fine
and he starts laughing and obviously
[ __ ] bud red mad meter
going off the but it's like dude how can
you be so unsavvy and also I explained
it to him three times I said it's fine I
literally looked at him I was like hey
man you got to relax it's all good
no one's popping air tags in your
[ __ ] back pocket because they want us
[ __ ] you know chain up the dude from
primer
it's a movie that [ __ ] won Sundance
that he was on
um
so anyway that's how we learned about
air tags and it [ __ ] ruined my show
but it's all good I [ __ ] still came
with it
all good still came with it
um
and I was on I went away this weekend to
a wedding with the family
to St Louis congratulations to the groom
and bride You Know Who You Are I won't
air out your business but it was a
wedding and it was beautiful and uh
and
um
you know I gotta tell you man
we got the flights last minute we got
Southwest and we [ __ ] were in the a
boarding group so we got good seats and
[ __ ] you know
and uh it was so fun with Calvin and
[ __ ] flying and then we got to the
wedding and
um
we're in the wedding the wedding was
great and it was hot in St Louis and
then the groom was like we should start
a fire out here and obviously everyone's
like what he was like we should put a
start a fire and I was like oh uh and
then he was like would it be too hot and
he asked somebody and somebody before I
chimed and they were like oh no go ahead
and I was and I looked at him and I go
all right well I'm not gonna I mean it's
80 degrees but you know and I was
sitting right near the fire
and the guy's like cool and he went to
go get matches or a [ __ ] lighter or
something and the guy said hey you know
you think it's too hot for fire and I
said I looked at the guy and I said yeah
man it's 80 degrees it's gonna be so hot
and he was like uh well I don't want to
tell him he's the groom it's his day and
I was like yeah all right [ __ ] it I'm
not gonna be the [ __ ] to be like it's
gonna be too hot
so sat there and I was getting hot as
[ __ ] dude like just straight up it was
80 degrees and now I'm sitting near a
fire I backed up a little bit like I'm a
hot as [ __ ] I'm in a suit it sucks to
have to wear a suit dude I don't know
how these Wall Street [ __ ] do
it or like people who literally wear
suits but like maybe it's because I
don't normally I'm not used to it but
what but having to get used to something
that's uncomfortable [ __ ] sucks like
I got I wear a straight up casual wear
you know I just saw my new balances and
now I'm wearing these [ __ ] however I
don't even know what the shoes are but
there's like blister City and like just
my belt is on and I'm sweating and I'm
in St Louis so it's a little bit humid
and now it fires up I'm so uncomfortable
and then I realize like holy [ __ ]
I'm actually hot as [ __ ] and super
uncomfortable but I'm not being a dick
about it
and I'm like
what's going on because usually if I'm
hot and uncomfortable
everyone knows it right in the past if I
was hot and uncomfortable you heard me
in a corner bitching to someone right
and it's [ __ ] things looking for fans
of [ __ ] lights on it's like a [ __ ] a
[ __ ] things from Summer and no open
somebody [ __ ] air on right fan do
[ __ ] [ __ ] fans that's what you heard
me doing but I'm not doing that stuff
I'm smiling watching people get married
the the fire's on it's fine the groom's
day whatever I just moved the seat back
a little bit and I realize and I'm I'm
trying to be like why do I feel straight
up like just leveled out and I I know
I've talked about this before but I the
only Aunt because dude I was in therapy
today
and like so
uh interested in what the [ __ ]
therapist was talking about and I'm like
like trying to actively learn and like
work on myself and I'm like what the
[ __ ] is going on and I'm talking to the
therapist and and she's like well you
know you were living life
uh and not experiencing these feelings
and everything's open and you're
experiencing these feelings because I
don't you know I don't like to be alone
I hate being with alone with myself she
was like but you know you have to learn
how to be that way otherwise you're not
really an adult and I agree with her and
and I and I think that [ __ ] dude
I I did I take this CBD and I swear to
God it [ __ ] levels me the [ __ ] out
and and that's the only thing that I can
[ __ ] pinpoint to what's making me not
making me not make people's lives
miserable around me and I used to do it
as comedy like yeah [ __ ] you know
yeah well it's too hot not make a laugh
about it and then secretly the groom
would be like hahaha but then instead be
like okay but it actually feels bad I
don't know you know but
anyway I take this pure Spectrum DVD DVD
CBD I take this pure Spectrum Red Box I
take this pure stretch Spectrum CBD and
I [ __ ] uh have a 10 off code for you
if you use CBD uh uh you go click on
it's in the show notes but it's um
you get 10 off and you if you if you
click the link and go out and use code
congrats at checkout but um
you know
it's it's absolutely [ __ ] hilarious
that I
I am less annoyed I guess
it really makes no [ __ ] sense I don't
know but I'm not gonna argue with it
because it feels [ __ ] fantastic I
used to think about like I used to think
like losing that pissed off chip on my
shoulder was gonna make me not funny or
not me but dude I'm me and I feel good
dude granted I also take [ __ ]
Citalopram but I've been doing that for
a long time uh and finasteride because I
think the wig's getting back a little
bit but you know no no big deal
um
foreign
I think going back because it's like you
know I don't know if it's scared of my
eyes or what but it's like [ __ ] [ __ ]
those eyes
[Music]
hey guys want to take a break here to
mention ship station uh look man it's a
great thing that I use myself and let me
tell you a little bit about it uh the
best time to prepare for growth is
before the opportunity arrives that's
just a life rule okay but especially for
online business ship station sets you up
for growth by directly integrating with
every shopping cart and storefront okay
so your products are easier to find
easier to manage and easier to get into
the hands of happy customers don't wait
until you're drowning in orders to find
the right shipping solution upgrade to
ship station today I use it with my
products online and we're ready for
anything including the holidays with
ship station don't sleep I'm telling you
do it now too late is too late and
that's something that I say all the time
all right so uh you're starting small or
scaling up ship station it makes ship
happen all right so whatever you're
using uh no more are limiting your
business to one store also shipstation
integrates with every platform including
Amazon Etsy eBay Shopify Etc you ever
heard of those or you live under a rock
don't be a dumbo okay get ship station
uh join over 130 000 companies who have
grown their Ecommerce business with
shipstation that's a lot of people you
ever seen 130 000 people in a room no
there's a reason for that ship more and
grow more with ship station go to
shipstation.com today and sign up with
promo code congrats for a free 60-day
trial start today and get set up before
the biggest shipping season of the year
that's two months free visit
shiftstation.com Click the microphone at
the top and type in code congrats
crazy crazy
I did I went to a wedding in uh
in St Louis and uh I walked into a
Starbucks and I don't know what it is
apparently like but like everybody in
the Starbucks was like Hey crystalia and
then the [ __ ] these people are like
are you Chrisley and then people are
doing here's the thing man if you're
Googling me in the [ __ ] Starbucks
I know you're doing it okay
dude people on planes like with their
[ __ ] whole laptop like it's the like
it's the Nebuchadnezzar in [ __ ] uh
just pulling me up and [ __ ] we got Tom
Cruise in [ __ ] 2f just like this
Googling pictures of me like on Minority
Report
like I did there was a dude sitting in
front of me one row on his computer it
wasn't even his computer it was like the
laptop with the [ __ ] [ __ ] ass
keyboard that you attached to it like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude just get a the
computers are so small just get a small
computer don't get a that's like one of
those guys who gets the truck and then
gets the little [ __ ] top cover for
the back of the truck it's like make up
your goddamn mind get a [ __ ] minivan
or a car or get a minivan or a truck you
don't get to have both it's annoying as
[ __ ]
and it's annoying if you have the
[ __ ] keyboard with the laptop or the
keyboard with the [ __ ] uh iPad
you don't get to have Best of Both
Worlds what is this [ __ ] uh Jay-Z and
R Kelly that [ __ ]
big chips
that's what that album is called Best of
Both Worlds
um and so uh
so yeah and he's Googling me Google
Imaging me which is even worse
because I see all these images of me and
I'm like I'm literally just like this
he's here and I'm just like looking at
me
hey guy have shame you know
but so I'm at Starbucks two different
people are Googling me and then or on my
Instagram or some [ __ ] and then some
lady comes up to me and she and I'm with
Calvin and Calvin's like drinking his
juice and [ __ ] and she was like hi I
know you hate this
um and I don't want to bother you when
you're with your kid
um but can you take a pic can we take a
picture and I was like
look just come up and ask for a picture
you know
just say hey can I get a picture
because
first of all let me just tell you right
now I don't hate when people come up and
ask me for a photo that's awesome I love
it I appreciate you and a lot of people
I think they mistake my [ __ ] humor
and my my I don't give a [ __ ] attitude
with
um
with uh
oh he doesn't want me to approach him
that that couldn't be further from the
truth I always enjoy when somebody comes
up and says something uh
and if you know if it's nice and so and
so I I don't hate it but
you're you think I do okay
so
you think I hate it
and also you're still doing it so that's
one right that's that's one that's like
I it actually it doesn't bother me but
just on the books
shitty shitty Behavior right on the
books Let's just if you wrote it down he
hates this and I did it okay check mark
shitty Behavior okay
[ __ ] whatever the [ __ ] I'm sure she's
a nice lady like I get
was was nice in her tone
then she says I don't want to interrupt
you and your kid but
as busy one would say part in my
[ __ ] interruption
but can I interrupt you with your kid so
two textbook shittinesses
I think people feel like they have to
say [ __ ] and then they end up saying too
much it's like a crook when they get
[ __ ] cornered and it's like I wasn't
anywhere I I was I was I was shopping
with my wife on January 19th and they're
like we didn't say anything about
January 19th
Clank
and so uh
yeah I don't know how she drowned we
didn't say she drowned
that's not public knowledge yet Clank so
um
so yeah just come up and ask for a
picture and say something nice and
that's all good dude but I appreciate
fans I love you guys dude I love you
guys
um twins came up to me and asked for a
picture that's always weird two dude
twins that were like [ __ ] 30. never
had that happen before did like you
playing a show here I'm like nah I'm
doing I'm here for a wedding next year
and they both go they both say cool
thanks Twins and [ __ ] twins are weird as
[ __ ]
right
because one of them has to be evil
one of them I mean on you know I get it
it's not like that simple and it's not
like cartoons but one of them is worse
so you're the evil twin just know if
you're a twin listen to this you're
either the evil twin or the good twin
and if you're the evil twin and you're
not taking over the world then you
failed or at least try you know try
inventing something if you're [ __ ] if
you're the worst twin you gotta try
inventing something or you're just
wasting your [ __ ] evil twin life
um
is are we pissed are we pissed off what
by the way the world is divided with the
[ __ ] our real uh swimmy girl what the
[ __ ] is it
Little Mermaid Ariel swimming girl and
um
she's black now which I don't give a
[ __ ] I don't care she's not real make
her [ __ ] make her a [ __ ] chair I
don't give a [ __ ] like it doesn't bother
me at all all right
and so Arielle is black they made her
black still gave her red hair weird
she's not Eve
you know
so uh and now this is hilarious so
people are mad you know they think it's
stupid that it's like how do you [ __ ]
up like people talking about the
sanctity of Disney like we don't give a
[ __ ] go [ __ ] yourself you know they get
rid of their pride colors the [ __ ]
second the clock hits Midnight at the
end of that month what is it June July I
don't know and um
pride month and so
um
yeah Tinkerbell flies across and does
the [ __ ] Disney swirl the second that
[ __ ] hits the end of pride month uh
midnight Tinkerbell goes yeah well [ __ ]
dude it just [ __ ] flies away
whenever they should marry [ __ ] it and
just flies away
ends yeah right
and so uh
yeah like Disney gives a [ __ ] so there
so Arielle is black now and um I could
give a rat's ass
but people are mad because they think
like you know they're [ __ ] up history
literally you know I assume a lot of
these people are white
uh because Arielle was drawn originally
White
which also has no legs so she's not real
she's got a fin instead of legs so
anyway pipe down but I don't give a [ __ ]
is it is it is it annoying the reason
yes the reason why it's annoying is
because you know Disney doesn't give a
[ __ ] about it but they're doing it
because they think that affects it
affects their bottom line and so here's
the deal so they made her black which
fine I give a [ __ ] like I said but now
people are mad at that and and woke
quote unquote people are mad that they
photoshopped
the black girl
and she doesn't seem as black
so
they lose again
my point is you can't ever be woke
enough this movement makes people uh
they eat their own so you can't win so
just from now on every Disney character
white it doesn't matter what the [ __ ]
white and I'm talking about
like The Cricket in Pinocchio now he's
white okay the trolls they're all white
I know they were pink and blue and [ __ ]
[ __ ] white dude this way you don't
get to be mad if oh well that one is
obviously the black one because of the
way it talks and he has a backwards hat
on or Jar Jar Binks he is white
you know
me so privileged and so
but I just think it's [ __ ]
you just can't win dude
so just like who you know
this whole world [ __ ]
I don't give a [ __ ]
what it doesn't matter what am I I'm the
old guy now or whatever
Ariel's black I think that she should be
black I think that everyone in that
movie should be black and I think that
it should be literally the blackest
movie I've ever [ __ ] seen
I don't know I should change ever since
the [ __ ] queen died you know
it's actually crazy that she died and
was alive for so long and they first of
all like you Britain
let's hurry up with the funeral you know
what I mean like they [ __ ]
it was like what did they [ __ ] wait
nine weeks dude they she died and then
she they had to like pass her body
around or whatever the [ __ ] play Hot
Potato with it you know
like just like they propped her up and
took some pictures with her and [ __ ]
they did Taxidermy on her [ __ ] face
it's like so it's like dude the
Traditions are so annoying
there's a [ __ ] actual in Italy
There's an actual
channel on Italian TV devoted to like
one of the old [ __ ] popes or some
[ __ ] and he's been dead for years
decades and he's just sitting there and
it's a live feed you know
it is on TV it's not like a twitch
Channel
and uh
like dude how about this man
like
to be think about like how annoying
everybody is to not be able to be
left alone
dead
I know you'd have no feeling about it
either way but like the disrespect the
utter that is the most Italian thing of
all time
well he dies but we cannot put up a live
stream about it
but don't you think it's disrespectful
it doesn't matter he doesn't have we
need to spare a respects it's for the
people
so there's a live feed of it and uh you
can do that and so now it's like
the queen is just finally been buried or
whatever the [ __ ] had her I don't know
what she was but they had her uh
what do you call it
funeral so that's great
good job good job Brits
uh well I think we should bury about an
hour like a weekend ah
well it's quite a few days you never
know
cousin could show up and want to see her
you know closure whatever we need to try
some other crowns on her too before we
pick the right one the burial in
uh what to say she's getting kind of uh
you know it's just a bit uh it's musty
I'll say in a room
underground or what
um
I can't believe like the the line of
waiting to see a dead person is 12 hours
or no it's something the people waited
for a day like 24 hours dude to think
that
like
sometimes like to get people in the in
the sh in my show it takes like an hour
to get everybody seated like the fact
that I don't have as much people aren't
ex don't have the same amount of
excitement to see me than they do a dead
lady
you know
just 20 like I ain't [ __ ]
because people will wait 24 times as
long to see
a dead chick so [ __ ] disrespectful to
call the Queen that but the truth is a
dead lady
then to see
like my hard work
so I ain't [ __ ] dude
um
but David Beckham was there and he
waited or something no he waited
imagine how about that dude if they made
Dev David Beckham wait 12 hours
Jesus dude
I would have had to wait [ __ ] they
would have made me wait extra I'd be
like I'm next and I'd be like oh just
hold on
David Beckham's 12-hour wait to pay his
respects how the queen ended in an
emotional moment
although it would have [ __ ] made me
wait I'd still be waiting she'd be
buried and be like nah we'll be right
with you
well did didn't you no hold on you were
canceled
all around the world people have been
mourning the loss to the Queen Elizabeth
II who passed away at the age of 96
December or a cinema
um
many have been lining up to pay the
respective on the soccer Superstar David
Beckham
wow and still look goddamn ravishing all
12 hours like just dressed like a
[ __ ]
just so Dapper you know wow the britons
police hats [ __ ] suck
you could keep a whole cake in there
the former footballer was first spotted
in the queue around 2 A.M 2 A.M Jesus I
did not end up making decide okay until
three what the [ __ ] this guy slept out
there the [ __ ] David Beckham's life you
know
yeah it doesn't matter I'll just he
sounds [ __ ] Australian to me 100 we
all want to be here together we all want
to experience something we are celebrate
an amazing life of our Queen he said wow
he waited 12 hours
wow
uh the British icon also explained that
he was there in honor of why is he
dressed like somebody from [ __ ] um
peaky blinders dude
that's amazing dude did you guys see
this
the [ __ ] lady who made here's
something that needs to stop for real I
thought this was a joke when I first saw
it if you're uh 80 or 70 don't make a
hip-hop video
it
hey Utah District listen up right here
there's a new name on the ballot for the
Senate this year I mean you know
there's the new name on it it's so high
dude it sounds crisp as [ __ ] like she
did it in a [ __ ] booth
turn me up in the headphones
Cincy
wow hey YouTube well listen up
there's a new name on the ballot for the
Senate this year my name is Linda
Paulson Republican and also I love God
and family and the Constitution it
doesn't rhyme we try to get another
conservative to rent I mean
you know
rhymed awesome with Constitution um
is that what you did Republican and
awesome love I mean so Republican and
awesome
in love with God and family and the
Constitution
family and the Constitution get another
conservative worst picture to use dude
so far away and blurry yeah
not even centered nobody could do it so
I'm getting it done I'm pro-religious
Freedom pro-life Pro police the right to
bear arms and the right to the only
rapper police government control and
regulation want to stop and expose all
political corruption with Integrity
morality
the government program should lead to
self-sufficiency and support traditional
family as the fundamental unit of
society I had in schools there push it
for new beliefs and just to clarify this
keep your dick that's a female adult I
know what a woman is
the hell Hitler at the end wow we gotta
watch this again
hey Utah District 12 listen the way she
turns around here so out of breath after
this you know like had to sit down and
[ __ ] actually put her hand to her
chest name on the ballot for the Senate
this year my name is Linda Republican
and awesome love God and family and the
Constitution I can't she hey you can
hear right lady Republican and awesome
I love God and family and the constant
awesome
I tried to get another conservative to
rent nobody could do it so I'm getting
it done
pro-life Pro police the right to bear
arms and the right to freeze feet I want
less government control and regulation
want to stop and expose all political
corruption with his Integrity morality
accountability government programs
should lead to self-sufficiency wow and
support traditional family as a
governmental unit of society but in
schools there pushing for new beliefs
worst shot of a school just to clarify
this because there's some who can't
Define this as a female adult I know
what a woman is it's a [ __ ] at the end
unbelievable dude when she goes like
this
just the picture of the [ __ ] lady
wanted to call her black so bad you know
um wow the comment here surprisingly
wholesome
somebody says yeah guy okay
no hey somebody who doesn't realize how
they're coming off
cannot lead okay
that's a big Whoopsie Daisy and of
course he's from Utah ah
um
I saw that movie [ __ ] I stayed dude
my friends were supposed to come over
last night they didn't and I was gonna
watch bad movies with them and they
[ __ ] bailed on me and I just go like
this [ __ ] you [ __ ] I'm watching
Beast by myself
dude I'll S I will stare at Idris Elba
for an hour and a half dude and just sit
here and eat
Cheerios mixed with Honey Nut Cheerios I
put them both at the same time because
Honey Nut Cheerios on their own is too
sweet and regular Cheetos on her own is
too [ __ ] plain and everyone knows it
so I sat there and watched Idris Elba
fight a [ __ ] lion for an hour and a
half by myself and I dude I had a blast
man and that movie's good
I don't know what it got on
on critics or whatever the [ __ ] but I
saw dude I watched F9 Fast and the
Furious and then I looked I I
I don't understand what F9 is you know
top 10 worst movies of all time like Vin
Diesel doesn't hey dude you that's not
the movie you're in guy you're not in
you know Thriller drama
[ __ ] everything serious movie guy
you're you're in a movie where a car
has an R B singer and a rapper in it and
it goes to outer space to save the world
a car
you're in a movie where a pro wrestler
John SEMA Cena who I would argue is the
worst looking man in human history
okay
[ __ ] uh aggressively advances off a
[ __ ]
ledge and [ __ ] in a car and zooms off
it and a [ __ ]
stealth bomber picks it up sit up in
midair
and Vin Diesel's like
seriously looking at another guy saying
stuff like
nah not this time I was there for you
and like doing it like for real hey do
it tongue-in-cheek it's F9
hey do it tongue-in-cheek you made nine
of these and the only reason why they're
[ __ ] Global box office phenomenons is
because of Asians
Asians don't give a
[ __ ] what they're watching dude Asians
will watch anything as long as something
in it Preposterous is happening
like they they don't give a [ __ ] dude
a white guy will watch the stealth
bomber pick up a [ __ ] car in midair
and and like I'll be like oh my god what
the [ __ ] Asians will watch it and eat
start eating more popcorn
it's the Asians don't give a [ __ ] as
long as action is happening right and
I'm including Indians with RR like all
that Bollywood [ __ ] they don't give a
[ __ ]
and there's so many of them that [ __ ]
Fast and Furious can be a hit now and
that's a conspiracy theory Hill that I'm
willing to die on
uh
yeah dude
so don't be all not tongue-in-cheek and
sitting there Vin Diesel talking to you
know somebody that's like it's actually
all about family and mean it dude get
out of here man
get you know
somebody who guy I [ __ ] dude vindi
John Cena is the ugliest man I've ever
seen in my life
I'll die on the hill dude have you ever
seen a close-up of him he looks
fantastic in the ring but you see a
close-up with that [ __ ] dude oh
you're just like where
we're going
is his face in a rush
parts of his face have other [ __ ] to do
today or something
it's a comedy podcast relax dude
I don't actually think John Cena is the
ugliest guy in the [ __ ] world I think
it's Kenneth Branagh obviously but dude
you know what I mean where's heck but
where's Kenneth brana's lips though
they use that extra flesh to populate
John Cena's [ __ ] face with like jowls
you know
God was like Kenneth doesn't need that
put it on John Cena's jowls
obviously I'm joking dude Kenneth Brana
is not the [ __ ] ugliest guy in the
world
I'm actually keep going with the joke
you know but it's just like
but yeah dude
just like
John Cena's where's his face going dude
John Cena's got the most faceiest face
since Steve Harvey
[Music]
um
the acting I know I know you don't watch
but so this is what my point is so I'm
watching F9 and then I look I'm like oh
this is agreed that this is one of the
worst movies we've ever seen right like
where do they get hey
like where do they get first of all who
are these guys in Fast and Furious
Furious who are these guys okay because
let's go back to Fast and the Furious
one
Paul Walker was an undercover cop that
met up with a street racer Vin Diesel
and they had to save the day or uncover
something or [ __ ] get bad guys
arrested okay
how did we get to
the ninth installment which is actually
the 10th installment because of Hobbs
and Shaw's in there somewhere
how the [ __ ] did they get to be Global
like International spies that like Vin
Diesel's like we're needed again
to save the world oh by what but who's
hiring you
you just some guy
and
who's ludicrous
and what it what is Tyrese
and how are they the comedic [ __ ]
element of the movie
cars will be flying off for Bridges and
Ludacris will be like
not in my wildest days whoa
and Tyrese will just be like damn
agents just eating popcorn more popcorn
just laughing their [ __ ] asses off
watching Fast and Furious and [ __ ] uh
you know
a big metropolitan area
ah dude
[ __ ] God damn dude nothing there's
only one thing more Asian than being in
a heavily populated metropolitan area is
being [ __ ] away way way not near
[ __ ] anybody do it in silence yeah
dude man
holy [ __ ] so but I will tell you this
man who who are these guys in the movie
just straight up who are they
1900 characters in each movie dude Kurt
Russell is in number nine in two scenes
shot it in one day it gave him four
million dollars took an afternoon
and like you know
who are these guys who is Charlize
Theron she's in a glass box the whole
movie
with a [ __ ] a Q-tip haircut
who are these people
then you got like Michelle Rodriguez who
I thought was Vin Diesel's sister until
they ended up kissing and I'm like oh oh
it's [ __ ] Jordana Brewster that's his
sister just there's too many people in
this movie
dude John Cena Vin Diesel the chick from
Game of Thrones that's now in that
invitation thing that used to follow me
on [ __ ] Instagram but doesn't anymore
and then [ __ ] uh
Jordana Brewster [ __ ] uh what's her
name uh the other one that I just said
Michelle Rodriguez
ludicrous Tyrese I'm racist because it
had to do black guys at the same time uh
the Asian dude that just acts like this
that's all he does well what do you
think he's just
we thought you died whoa not today
just ludicrous [ __ ] yucking it up
God Ludacris the worst act I've ever
seen in my life dude
they tell hey also
in oh I forgot the best part John Cena
is Vin Diesel's brother
[Laughter]
John Cena
is Vin Diesel's brother in the movie
they don't look alike
dude and there's this there's a and then
it might have been okay if they were
adopted but they don't mention that as a
matter of fact they make it worse they
say oh I knew I noticed that jawline and
the and the face structure was familiar
saying like that they actually were
brothers dude
ah
if they cast straight up if they cast a
[ __ ] doorway instead of John Cena it
would have been more believable
dude Vin Diesel looks more like a
doorway than John Cena
is Vin Diesel even white I don't even
know what the [ __ ]
dude unbelievable that their brothers in
the movie dude dude
here's another question who's funding
this mission
it's hey Street racer we need help to
save the world can you find this orb
that's in the wrong hands here's 84
bajillion dollars this seems a pro-free
appropriate
honey does it
wow dude just unbelievable I can't even
believe it
that Asian guy is in it and it's so
funny dude
like he's that he like
he died in the movie before and died and
then they were like
how you alive and then he's just like
and they do some flashback where instead
of him being in the car that blew up
he's watching the car that blew up
and then he shows up and he has a
haircut you know to make him look older
he just [ __ ] has a haircut and [ __ ]
and then and then it goes and then it
goes and then one of the guys says to
him well that still leaves one thing
that has to be left explained and and
then I and then I said to my friends we
were watching it I said your haircut and
they all laughed really hard
[Music]
dude that movie dude F also the balls to
call it F9 made half a billion dollars
it cost it made 750 or 20 30 40 50
million dollars cost 200 something
million dollars to make so much [ __ ]
money just being thrown around dude and
and Kurt Russell's in two scenes and
then at the end he's he his character's
name is Mr Nobody dude a children's game
so bad and and then isn't discussed
Beyond halfway through in the throughout
the movie and the movie ends and there's
like no Kurt Russell and then three days
later you think wait a minute Kurt
Russell was in that movie
and they're making another one
they're just waiting for the CGI to get
good enough because because they just
cut Paul Walker out because he died that
they're just gonna wait till the CGI is
good enough to where they're gonna I
swear to God I [ __ ] you not to where
they can CGI and have Paul Walker in the
whole movie CGI and that's what they're
gonna do and I'm telling you right now
dude and they've already put ludicrous
and Tyrese in space in a car and they
had to crash into a satellite this is
all real [ __ ]
um
movie's so bad but it's great and then I
went down the [ __ ] critic this whole
reason why I brought up and the critics
and and like half the critics were like
popcorn fun no
still gotta make sense dude
you know the acting may not be there but
the action is absolutely non-stop yeah
but it's bad dude the special effects
okay but also this is a movie
I could just type cool special effects
on YouTube and come up with them it's
just so bad dude
um
oh come on
oh God Vin Diesel dead
do you know his real name I do it's Mark
Sinclair
a [ __ ] lawyer you know
well judge that would be cool but he
didn't do it why
family
drives out of the [ __ ] Courtyard
knocks over a fountain
diesel said he prefers to maintain his
privacy regarding his personal life
stating dude he saw somebody I went to
would have went to NYU for one year with
uh stating I'm not gonna put it out
there on a magazine cover like some
other actors I come from the
Harrison Ford Marlon Brando Robert De
Niro Al Pacino Code of Silence
lump Harrison Ford in there you know
not part of it
I'm from [ __ ] I'm from the Harry I'm
from the Marlon Brando Robert De Niro Al
Pacino Drew Carey Code of Silence
what Harrison Ford was in Zero Italian
movies Dakota silence is Italian
you know
I'm from the I'm from the Marlon Brando
Robert De Niro Al Pacino Frankie Muniz
Code of Silence we don't talk about our
private life
the guy's Instagram is unreal too Vin
Diesel oh such a kink in his neck here
with the [ __ ] uh what's his name
Michael Marco kind I couldn't think of
his name until I did that one of the fun
one of the best this is his caption one
of the best things about filming in the
UK dinners with my dear friend Sir
Michael Kane who adoringly refers to me
as his son ah
dude all love always I love people who
sign their Instagram captions all love
always dude it's not a [ __ ] letter
you're gonna give to a pigeon
kink in his neck you know how much does
Vin Diesel wear the worst clothes of all
time I've never seen him in his regular
clothes only in action clothes but
wow these two guys are probably so
[ __ ] imagine being at a dinner with
goddamn Michael Kane and Vin Diesel you
I swear to God 20 minutes in I'd be like
dude I I come out I'm out dude I'm out
I'm out I can't do this dude
you [ __ ] guys kidding me you don't
know what real life is life
okay I'm looking here another Instagram
wow yeah this [ __ ] Michael Caine also
not a Code of Silence
one of the best things about filling
your dinner Sir Michael Kane you can't
be a [ __ ] in the code is silence with
19 bajillion Instagram followers you
know
I love how much the rock hates [ __ ]
Vin Diesel too you know it dude you know
it they asked him to come back and they
and he said no and it was because of Vin
Diesel I think and then that that's
[ __ ]
um
but I did see that movie beast and that
was good dude it was good
okay it's like Jaws but with a lion and
the extent
that with the extent of how they went
of the how far they went to not say that
is unbelievable like
it's jaws with a lion
that's what it is
and if you're a [ __ ] you might think
well it's no lines in the water I think
oh it's the Jungle the desert the South
the South African and and the [ __ ]
Idris elba's the guy
and they the the the the amount
that they don't say that is unbelievable
because
here's the thing when the rock made that
movie where he's the amputee in the
building skyscraper is that what it's
called whatever it was everyone was like
dude he has to get his family out of the
[ __ ] building From the Terrace this
is die hard and immediately the rockos
puts up an Instagram post and says this
movie I'm so proud of because I was such
a huge fan of Die Hard it's an Ode to
die hard and then everyone chilled out
right
because they asked I watched behind the
scenes of the ship because I have
[ __ ] obsessive compulsive disorder
and when I watch a movie I want to watch
everything I can after it involving the
movie right like if Beast had a prequel
I would have already seen that [ __ ]
and um
and I watched uh the [ __ ] uh
behind the scenes and and they were like
Idris Mr elbow [ __ ] last name is
always elbow you know uh Idris what is
the [ __ ] is this a are there other
movies like this is this a first it was
like well I think it's actually a first
you know what I mean because like yeah
sure there's been other movies where
like I always forget that he's [ __ ]
British because he's got such a good
he's a great actor dude and it's
hilarious he's a DJ too like literally
[ __ ] gets paid to like spiny Bita
but he was like um you know if you know
he's got that family element there too
there's a lot of going behind the scenes
so I mean in a way there is that it is a
first but also you know it's been done
before but like this way not in this way
and it's like oh okay Idris Elba here's
another guy that's gonna be [ __ ] out
to lunch with [ __ ] Vin Diesel and
Michael Kane in a few in a few years you
get to that level of craziness at
Hollywood dude I'm so glad I'm out of
that [ __ ] I will not be crazy and I
am not crazy and I [ __ ] go to therapy
because I want to go to therapy not
because of this performative [ __ ]
that these people like to be like oh you
know mental health is real and then they
go out and [ __ ] you know
I don't know Robert jewelry store I
don't know I can't think of a [ __ ] I
don't I don't give a [ __ ]
but anyway dude
um one thing I know for sure is Vin
Diesel absolutely has a Code of Silence
and that's so [ __ ] cool
um you guys
[ __ ] yeah remember that Lifeline uh live
show watch lifeline.com get your tickets
there talk live me and my brother uh on
the show it's October 19th Matt's
birthday show uh and then come see me on
tour chrisleya.com and we've got those
life rips jackets there is an absolute
limited edition uh for those jackets
so go get him while you still can well
guys that's it for the episode this week
on YouTube if you want to catch the rest
of the episode The Raw the uncut episode
the patreon version unedited on with no
commercials go to patreon.com Chris
Delia and sign up now and you also get
an extra episode a month you also get a
link to our Discord where we chat all
the time you also get uh review mode
which is another thing that I do where I
review [ __ ] on the patreon and uh
different podcasts I think there's right
now there's 17 extra episodes on there
that we've been doing or something like
that so if you sign up now you can watch
all 17 of them for just six bucks
there's also a podcast I did with
Kristen one episode and I think we're
doing another one real soon just sign up
for the patreon patreon.com crystalia
thanks
[Music]